Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I'm going to
explain an American science fiction thriller
film called “The Thinning New World Order.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
It is 2039 and the Earth has become overpopulated,
and all nations must annually cut their
populations by 5%. The United States implements
the rule called "Thinning." In the thinning,
the students must attend a standardized test every
year. In the test, whoever fails is executed.
However, the thinning scoring system was rigged.
The Officials manipulated the results to pass
whoever they want, usually the children of rich
parents. In the end, the foul play of the scoring
system was exposed by a student named Laina.
Blake Redding, the son of Texas Governor, Dean
Redding, failed the ‘thinning test’. He and the
others who failed the test were to be executed.
However, unknown to the public, they were instead
sent to an underground slave labor facility
to manufacture goods like phones and electronics
for a company called Assuru Global. This way,
the company profits off cheap labor.
It is now the following day of the thinning.
Blake and the other students who had failed
are brought to the underground facility.
There, they watch a video of a lady explaining
that they are the chosen ones, who get a second
chance at life. The place is called an incubator
and is designed by Assuru. They have been brought
here to work for the company. Lastly, she reveals
that the most productive member of the incubator
program gets reintroduced to society. The
people happily celebrate being alive.
The system then tells them to go to their
respective assignment room. A teaching device has
been inserted in all of their necks. An automated
voice explains to them their tasks and routines.
They will have to work for fourteen hours a day
before they get one hour of dining and personal
time. They will also get curfews, in which they
have to go to their assigned beds and rest. While
watching the videos, Blake notices his long-lost
girlfriend, Ellie, in a clip. Blake goes looking
for her and the two finally meet. Blake cannot
believe that she is alive. Ellie tells him to meet
her in an hour when they have a curfew. The two
meet at the living unit, and have sex. Later that
night, Blake is talking to his friend, Heather,
when a siren starts ringing in the facility.
One of the workers is trying to commit suicide
because he doesn’t want to work anymore. A group
of boys from below encourage the boy to jump. Cage
is the leader of a group. The boy eventually jumps
,but the guards lay the nets right before and save
him. It turns out that anyone who refuses to work,
is sent to an infirmary where they are injected
with some kind of drug to docile them.
Cage then comes to meet Blake at his living unit.
He tells him that Ellie is his girlfriend now,
and he should stay away from her. The following
day at the cafeteria, Ellie sits alone at a
table when Cage approaches and kisses her. Ellie
seems uncomfortable the whole time. Heather and
Blake watch the event unfold from their table,
but cannot do anything. Cage and his team are
called ‘the worthy’. They are hand-selected
by the incubator to supervise other workers.
After the group leaves the table, Blake
approaches Ellie. Frightened for his safety,
she asks him to go away. Just then, Cage’s men
approach Blake and tell him to leave Ellie alone.
Blake fights the men, but soon, Cage
intervenes and overpowers Blake.
Ellie and Blake manage to run away from the
cafeteria, but they are then caught by Mason King,
the ex-supervisor of the thinning exam who
has been relocated to the incubator after
the thinning scandal. After catching him,
Mason twists Blake’s leg and breaks it.
Back in the town of Texas, everyone is at Blake’s
memorial service, as Blake is presumed dead by the
public after he failed the test, Many reporters
try to interview his father, Governor Dean,
as he exits the premises. Laina has been on the
press’s radar after she successfully exposed the
foul play of the thinning's scoring system.
The reporters try
to interview her, but she dismisses them.
The thinning fraud incident has caused a
huge dent in Dean’s reputation. He managed to
blame the foul scoring system on Mason King,
the exam supervisor, but the DPC has appointed a
private investigator named Agent Joanne Morris,
to investigate the incident.
Agent Joanne visits Laina at her home the
following day. However, Laina doesn’t provide her
with any important information, so Joanne gives
Laina her card and leaves. Just then, a man knocks
on her door. It is a security guard named Jack,
who has come to invite Laina to meet Dean.
Later, we see Laina at Dean’s, he reveals that
he wants her help in his campaign
for the presidential election.
She strictly denies the job and leaves.
On her way, she meets Assuru Global’s CEO,
Georgina Preston. Assuru Global helps Dean
financially in his election campaigns, hence
Dean and Georgina work together closely. Georgina
vaguely tells Laina that she should consider the
job for her siblings, Corrine and Joey. She
tries bribing her, saying that her siblings
don’t have to appear for the thinning test if
she works for them, but she still refuses.
As Jack drives them back, he goes further
than Laina’s home. When she points it out,
some kind of gas begins to fill the car and
makes Laina and her siblings unconscious.
Laina wakes up in a deserted construction site,
with Jack and a few others standing in front of
her. Corrine’s elementary school teacher, Miss
Cole, is there too. It turns out that Jack and
Miss Cole work for an organization called
‘the fight’, which is against the thinning
system. If Dean is elected as the president, the
thinning will never end so they need Laina’s help
to work as their spy. They want her to take
the job Dean just provided. Laina agrees.
Meanwhile, Laina’s best friend, Kellan, gets a
job as an intern in the Tv news company with a
news reporter named Wendy Banks. That day,
Kellan is doing his research on the after
process of thinning. He realizes that no one
handles the dead bodies after execution.
At night he goes to Laina’s, and
asks her to join him at the cemetery.
The two go there and dig up Blake’s grave ,and
are surprised, to find his coffin empty.
Cut to eight months later. It is two weeks until
the election date. Dean has been campaigning for
the elections and Laina continues working in his
support. She has also been constantly providing
Miss Cole with all the information she could
gather. That day, they meet at a construction
site again. Laina is furious at being made to
support Dean Redding’s ideas. She accuses them
of doing nothing they promised to. Miss Cole calms
her down, and tells her that they now know that
all the necessary information is in Georgina’s
computer. They provide her with a device to
access her computer. Laina has to now figure out a
way to get to Georgina’s computer undetected.
Meanwhile, Blake and the others have been working
in the incubator for the past eight months too.
Blake’s leg has still not healed. He limps when
he walks. He has not been able to communicate
with Ellie either. That night, Cage and his group
come into Blake’s living area while he is asleep.
They gag him and hit his leg repeatedly
as he whimpers in pain. The following day,
he goes to Dr. Langley’s clinic and tells her
that he fell in the shower. When he comes back,
he tells Heather to inform Ellie to be
at Cage’s boxing match the next day.
Meanwhile, Kellan manages to crack the secret of
the labour camps, saying Assuru Global doesn't
have a manufacturing area on their campus and
they have been insourcing military rations
from a company called TXPak, being able to
serve food to 100,000 people per year.
However, his boss Wendy dismisses him, saying
that without a photo or video evidence, they
cannot publish the story. When he gets in his car
that day, a masked man from the back seat tries to
suffocate him. He somehow manages to free himself
and flees to Laina’s house. He knows that someone
from Assuru is always listening, so he informs
Laina of his revelations by writing in a notebook.
It is now the day of the election. Laina drops
her siblings off at Miss Cole’s and leaves for the
Assuru’s building, where Dean and his supporters
patiently wait for the election results.
Laina kisses Jack in the elevator, and the
two wish each other luck. Sometime later,
Laina goes to the restroom, where
a security guard escorts her.
Meanwhile, at the incubator, Blake is at one of
Cage’s matches when he presents himself to fight
Cage. The whole crowd watching the match goes
silent. Blake wants to be the leader of the group
if he wins. Cage agrees to the challenge. They
then fight. Even though Blake’s leg is injured, he
overpowers Cage. The crowd starts chanting Blake’s
name. After an intense fight, Blake wins.
Meanwhile, Ellie is in her bed and isn’t moving.
When the guards come near her, she attacks them,
determined to get out of the facility.
The guards eventually restrain her and take her
to the infirmary for her punishment. After his
win, Blake gathers Cage’s group and tells them
that none of the students from the thinning are
killed. They are brought down for cheap labor. He
also reveals that the reintroduction to society
is a lie and they will be stuck there forever.
After a lot of convincing, the group finally
agrees to work together to fight the system.
Blake and one of the guys go to get Ellie,
while others go to the cafeteria.
Laina on the other hand jumps out of the
bathroom’s window and somehow manages to
reach Georgina’s office. There, she uses the hard
drive that Miss Cole gave her to gain access to
the computer. She finds out all the camera footage
from the incubator, and is beyond surprised and
delighted to see that Blake is alive. She quickly
transfers all the information to the hard drive.
However, while she is in the office, Georgina
is about to come in. Jack stalls her,
saying that Dean wants to meet her urgently. Till
then, Laina takes the hard drive and gets back
to the restroom. However, after being caught in a
lie, Jack is restrained by the guards. Laina then
quickly calls agent Joanne Morris, who had been
appointed to investigate the thinning’s case.
At the incubator, Blake deliberately hurts
himself to be taken to the clinic where Ellie is.
There, he and a friend get rid of a guard, and
stop the doctors from injecting Ellie with a drug.
The two then take out the tracking device in their
necks and flee. In the cafeteria, Cage and a guy
start a fight, as their plan to stall the guards.
Soon, all the other workers join creating chaos.
Mason gets to know this and goes
to the cafeteria with other guards.
He is furious and checks Blake’s tracking
device to see he is in the clinic.
Meanwhile, Laina and Joanne meet at a terrace.
Laina gives her the hard drive and tells her
everything she knows about Assuru. Joanne
gets all the information she needs. But it
turns out that Joanne too is corrupt, and works
for Assuru. She then holds Laina at gunpoint.
Laina somehow defends herself and
manages to run away with the hard drive.
She goes to Kellan, who makes a copy of the
file to take it to Wendy to broadcast it. Laina
stays at his house for her safety. However, as
Kellan starts his car, it explodes, killing him.
Joanne and some men come looking for Laina. She
sets up a trap and runs out through the back door.
The guards fall into the trap, creating an
explosion. However, Joanne comes out unharmed.
She attacks Laina again; but this time, Laina
pushes her off the stairs, killing her.
Meanwhile, Jake and Ellie dress up as the nurses
and run through the basement of the incubator.
Mason follows them behind. The two find a ladder
reaching the top of the tunnel and climb up,
eventually getting out of it. They celebrate
happily, and are about to run when Mason
reaches there and attacks them.
Elsewhere, at the Assuru building,
the election results come out in the favor
of Dean. Everyone celebrates happily. He is
now the new president of the United States.
Meanwhile, Laina finally reaches the BNC News
centre, and shows Wendy Banks the proof. They
quickly rush to the opening of the incubator
in a chopper. They broadcast Mason fighting
Blake. Dean sees the broadcast and is beyond
surprised to see his son still alive. Still, he
gives his first presidential speech. Dean’s PA
tells Georgina that there is no way around this
scandal now. However, Georgina has a plan. She
arrests everyone who ever talked against Redding,
and plans to end democracy once and for all.
Blake and Laina finally reunite and kiss.
They stop when Laina sees Ellie behind Blake.
Just then, they too are arrested for
speaking against the thinning test.
As the police drive them, they get into an
accident but thankfully are not injured. Suddenly,
Jake comes to them and frees them. Jack tells
them that they will defeat Redding and Georgina,
and take things back to normal. The movie
ends abruptly hinting at the third sequel.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a
like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.